PROFESSOR: Delta
function potential.
So it's still a one-dimensional
potential-- potential
is a function of x.
We'll write it this
way-- minus alpha delta
of x, where alpha is positive.
So this is a delta function
in a negative direction.
So if you want to
draw the potential--
there's no way to draw really
nicely a delta function.
So you just do a thick
arrow with it pointing down.
It's a representation of
a potential that, somehow,
is rather infinite
at x equals zero--
but infinite and negative.
It can be thought of as the
limit of a square well that
is becoming deeper and deeper.
And, in fact, that
could be a way
to analytically
calculate the energy
levels-- by taking carefully
the limit of a potential.
It is becoming thinner and
thinner, but deeper and deeper,
which is the way you define or
regulate the delta function.
You can imagine
the delta function
as a sequence of
functions, in which it's
becoming more and more narrow--
but deeper at the same time.
So that the area under the
curve is still the same.
So, at any rate, the delta
function potential is
a potential that should be
understood as 0 everywhere ,
else except at the delta
function where it becomes
infinite.
And there are all kinds
of questions we can ask.
OK.
Are there bound states?
What are bound
states in this case?
They are energy eigenstates
with energy less than zero.
So bound states, which
means e less than zero.
Do they exist?
Does this potential
have bound states?
And, if it does, how
many bound states?
1, 2, 3?
Does It depend on the intensity
of the delta function?
When you get more bound states,
the deeper the potential is.
Well, we'll try to figure out.
In fact, there's a lot
that can be figured out
without calculating, too much.
And it's a good habit to try
to do those things before you--
not to be so impatient
that you begin,
and within a second
start writing
the differential equation
trying to solve it.
Get a little intuition about
how any state could look like,
and how could the answer
for the energy eigenstates--
the energies--
what could they be?
Could you just reason
your way and conclude
there's no bound states?
Or one bound state?
Or two?
All these things
are pretty useful.
So one way, as you can
imagine, is to think of units.
And what are the
constants in this problem?
In this problem we'll
have three constants.
Alpha, the mass of the
particle, and h-bar.
So with alpha, the
mass and the particle,
and h-bar you can ask, how
do I construct the quantity
with units of energy?
If there there's only one
way to construct the quantity
with units of energy, then
the energy of a bound state
will be proportional
to that quantity--
because that's the only quantity
that can carry the units.
And here, indeed,
there's only one way
to construct that quantity
with units of energy--
from these three.
That's to be expected.
With three constants that
are not linearly dependent--
whatever that is
supposed to mean--
you can build anything that has
units of length, mass, or time.
And from that you
can build something
that has units of energy.
So you can now decide, well,
what are the units of alpha?
The units of alpha
have give you energy,
but the delta function has
units of one over length.
This has one over length.
, Remember if you integrate over
x the delta function gives you
1.
So this has units
of 1 over length.
And, therefore,
alpha has to have
units of energy times length.
So this is not quite enough
to solve the problem,
because I want to write e--
think of finding how do
you get units of energy
from these quantities?
But l-- we still don't
have a length scale either.
So we have to do a
little more work.
So from here we say that units
of energy is alpha over l.
There should be a
way to say that this
is an equality between units.
I could put units or
leave it just like that.
So in terms of units, it's this.
But in terms of units, energy--
you should always remember--
is p squared over m.
And p is h-bar over a length.
So that's p squared
and that's m.
So that's also units of energy
From these two you can get
what has units of length.
Length.
You pass the l to
this side-- the l
squared to this left-hand side.
Divide.
So you get l is h
squared over m alpha.
And if I substitute
back into this l here,
e would be alpha over l, which
is h squared, alpha squared, m.
So that's the quantity
that has units of energy.
M alpha squared over h
squared has units of energy.
If this has units of energy--
the bound state energy.
Now, if you have a
bounce state here,
it has to decay in order
to be normalizable.
In order to be normalizable
it has to decay,
so it has to be in the
forbidden region throughout x.
So the energy as we
said is negative,
energy of a bound
state-- if it exists.
And this bound
state energy would
have to be negative some number
m alpha squared over h squared.
And that's very
useful information.
The whole problem
has been reduced
to calculating a number.
It better be and the answer
cannot be any other way.
There's no other way to
get the units of energy.
So if a bound state
exists it has to be that.
And that number could be
pi, it could be 1/3, 1/4,
it could be anything.
There's a naturalness
to that problem
in that you don't expect
that number to be a trillion.
Nor do you expect that number
to be 10 to the minus 6.
Because there's no way-- where
would those numbers appear?
So this number should be
a number of order one,
and we're going to wait
and see what it is.
So that's one thing we know
already about this problem.
The other thing we can do is
to think of the regulated delta
function.
So we think of this as a
potential that has this form.
So here is v of
x, and here is x.
And for this potential--
if you have a bound state--
how would the wave
function look?
Well, it would have to--
suppose you have
a ground state--
it's an even potential.
The delta function is even, too.
It's in the middle.
It's symmetric.
There's nothing asymmetric
about the delta function.
So if it's an even
potential the ground states
should be even, because
the ground state
is supposed to have no nodes.
And it's supposed to be even
if the potential is even.
So how will it look?
Well, it shouldn't be
decaying in this region.
So, presumably, it decays here.
It decays there-- symmetrically.
And in the middle it curves
in the other direction.
It is in an allowed region--
and you remember that's
kind of allowed this way.
So that's probably
the way it looks.
Now, if that bound
state exists, somehow,
as I narrow this and go down--
as it becomes even more narrow,
very narrow now, but very deep.
This region becomes smaller.
And I would pretty much
expect the wave function
to have a discontinuity.
You basically don't
have enough power
to see the curving
that is happening here.
Especially because the
curving is going down.
The distance is going down.
So if this bound state
exists, as you approach
the limit in which this
becomes a delta function
the energy moves a little, but
stays finite at some number.
And the curvature that is
created by the delta function
is not visible, and the thing
looks just discontinuous
in its derivative.
So this is an intuitive
way to understand
that the wave
function we're looking
for is going to be
discontinuous on its derivative.
Let's write the
differential equation,
even though we're still
not going to solve it.
So what is the
differential equation?
Minus h squared over
m, psi double prime,
is equal to E psi.
And, therefore-- and I
write this, and you say,
oh, what are you writing?
I'm writing the
differential equation
when x is different from 0.
No potential when x
is different from 0.
So this applies for
positive x and negative x.
It doesn't apply at x equals 0.
We'll have to deal
with that later.
So then, no potential
for x different from 0.
And this differential
equation becomes
psi double prime equals minus
2m e over h squared psi.
And this is equal
to kappa squared
psi, where kappa squared is
minus 2me over h squared.
And it's positive.
Let's make that positive.
It's positive because
the energy is negative
and we're looking
for bound states.
So we're looking for
bound states only.
Kappa squared is positive.
And this differential
equation is just this.
I'll copy it again here.
Kappa squared psi.
And the solutions of this
equation are-- solutions--
are e to the minus kappa
x and e to the kappa x.
Or, if you wish, cosh
kappa x and sinh kappa x--
whichever you prefer.
This is something we
now have to use in order
to produce a solution.
But now, let's see
if I can figure out
how many bound states there are.
If there is one bound state,
it's going to be even.
It's the ground state.
It has no nodes.
It has to be even, because
the potential is even.
If I have the first excited
state after the ground state,
it will have to be odd.
It would have to vanish at x
equals 0, because it's odd.
There is it's node--
it has to have one node.
For an odd bound state--
or first excited state--
you'd have to have psi
equals 0 at x equals 0.
And the way to do that would
be to have a sinh, because this
doesn't vanish at zero.
This doesn't vanish at zero.
And cosh doesn't vanish at zero.
So you would need psi of
x equals sinh of kappa x.
But that's not good.
sinh of kappa x is
like this and blows up.
Blows down.
It has to go like this.
It is in a forbidden
region, so it has
to be convex towards the axis.
And convex here.
But it blows up.
So there's no such solution.
No such solution.
You cannot have an
odd bound state.
So since the bound states
alternate-- even, odd, even,
odd, even, odd--
you're stuck.
You only will have a ground
state-- if we're lucky--
but no excited state that is
bound, while a finite square
will.
You remember this
quantity z0 that
tells you how many bound
states you can have.
Probably you're anticipating
that in the case
of the delta function
potential, you can only
have one bound state, if any.
The first excited
state would not exist.
So, enough preliminaries.
Let's just solve that now.